[Música]
el vice-presidente mike pence y la
demócrata kamala harris tuvieron un
debate más mesurado pero de choque de
hit que giró en torno a la gestión de la
pandemia y la vacuna para el coronavirus
un reflejo de la polarización que vive
eeuu la economía las tensiones
comerciales con otros países y el cambio
climático también se abordaron
mientras el rebrote de coronavirus
impacta a europa donde se disparan los
contagios en países como república checa
francia alemania e italia la primera ola
de la pandemia registrar récords en el
continente americano lado de maese
señala que américa latina se acerca a
los 10 millones de casos de esos hay más
de 5 millones en brasil
primera esperanza de un posible cese el
fuego después de casi dos semanas de
combates en el territorio separatista de
nagorno karabaj con los contactos
iniciales en ginebra entre los
mediadores internacionales en el
conflicto entre armenia y azerbaiyán
reporteros de france 24 se reunieron con
habitantes en el lado a cilic
hola como estan saludamos con mucho
gusto a todos ustedes que nos siguen por
la señal de france 24 hoy que es jueves
8 de octubre están bienvenidos
empezamos en eeuu y es que los
candidatos a la vicepresidencia el
republicano mike pence y la demócrata
kamala harris debatieron por temas como
el manejo de las pandemias del cob y 19
la economía el aborto el acuerdo de
parís el medio ambiente o la guerra
comercial con china esto en su único
cara a cara previo a las elecciones del
3 de noviembre contrario a lo ocurrido
con los aspirantes a la presidencia en
este encuentro
primaron las ideas de cada campaña sobre
las descalificaciones personales
los ataques más directos anoche llegaron
de harris que calificó el gobierno de
trump como el mayor fracaso de cualquier
administración presidencial en la
historia a la que culpó por ocultar
información sobre el coronavirus
mientras el propio presidente y varios
miembros de la casa blanca están siendo
tratados por el kobe 19
y mirar el pueblo estadounidense ha sido
testigo del que ha sido el mayor fracaso
de cualquier administración presidencial
en la historia de nuestro país
y podría imaginarse si ustedes hubieran
sabido el 28 de enero en vez del 13 de
marzo lo que ellos sabían lo que ustedes
habrían hecho para prepararse ellos
sabían y lo encubrieron el presidente
dijo que era un engaño el presidente
dijo están en un lado si usan una
mascarilla están del otro lado si no lo
hacen avanzar
la realidad es que cuando uno mira el
plan de bailén está lleno de ideas que
ya hemos hecho nosotros es lo que el
presidente de trump y yo hemos hecho con
nuestras fuerzas de tarea y en cada
momento y francamente cuando ves su plan
en el que habla de crear pruebas
avanzadas nuevos equipos de protección
desarrollar una vacuna para ese plagio
que es algo sobre lo que yo bien sabe un
poco no solo el verbo mire para analizar
este tema político y el debate nos
acompaña desde buenos aires el analista
sergio berensztein él es presidente y
director general de btr einstein
muchas gracias por esta comunicación a
pesar que tanto pensé
harris priorizar o no cometer errores y
evitaron las preguntas más
comprometedoras cómo podría este debate
vicepresidencial alterar la dinámica de
las encuestas de opinión a 26 días para
los comicios del 3 de noviembre
ustedes saben la campaña en los eeuu se
transformó severamente a partir de el
viernes de la semana pasada cuando fue
internado el presidente de donald trump
a partir de ese momento obviamente él
ocupó otra vez el centro de la escena y
si bien en los primeros sondeos surge
que la diferencia en el voto a nivel
nacional a favor del yo bailén
bueno se extendió significativamente en
los estados claves que van a definir la
elección tiene en cuenta el colegio
electoral todavía quedan dudas
significativas en particular en el
estado de la florida de arizona carolina
del norte pensilvania michigan wisconsin
es cierto que en la mayoría de ellos hay
una ventaja todavía a favor de bailén
pero en muchos casos esto no es
estadísticamente significativo síntesis
creo que ahora ha empezado una nueva
campaña mucho más polémica donde las
diferencias ideológicas políticas y
personales se van a evidenciar y creo
que recién tendremos una idea de como
sea
asignado las preferencias como se han
reordenado la preferencia de los
votantes independientes al fin de esta
semana seguramente hacia el viernes
sábado el domingo esta semana tendremos
ya nuevos grados ya nos tocaba el tema
señor beinstein este debate confirma que
el ganador de las elecciones del 2020 va
a depender de la pandemia de coronavirus
la pandemia obviamente se instaló en la
agenda global solamente en los eeuu yo
creo que en ese sentido lo que estamos
viendo es que en los países donde hay
elecciones o aún donde hay debates
parlamentarios siempre polémicas
respecto de lo que han hecho los
gobiernos frente a este desafío
nadie tiene naturalmente una teoría al
respecto es un hecho absolutamente
novedoso y siempre hay críticas ustedes
pueden tomar cualquier país y siempre
haber crítica respecto de la política
desplegada en este caso en particular
creo que lo más importante es la
controversia generada la enfermedad del
presidente de trump el hecho de que él
se fue al hospital apenas a los 4 días
de haber sido internado hay dudas
respecto obviamente de todo el
procedimiento empleado en ese sentido
del hecho que se sacó la mascarilla ni
bien llegó a la casa blanca
todas esas polémicas me parece que
resignifican la cuestión como bill más
allá de las consecuencias económicas
sociales que han sido devastadoras en el
mundo entero
y este cara cara al ser más mesurado y
tocar temas polémicos como la migración
el aborto el cambio climático podría
considerarse más como un debate real lo
que vimos anoche
el debate de anoche fue indudablemente
de mayor nivel y menos interrumpido que
el debate presidencial que tuvimos el
martes de la semana anterior creo que
también los protagonistas tiene estas
características son ambos mucho más
jóvenes y tienen creo yo una dinámica
más afín al parlamento recuerda ustedes
que el vicepresidente malpensa antes de
ser el gobernador de indiana estuvo en
el congreso fue representante y fue un
representa muy activo se siente cómoda
la palabra estuvo en el periodismo
muchos años y obviamente cámaras a
grises muy conocidas por su habilidad en
el manejo de la palabra fue una persona
muy importante en california
como este término y por supuesto también
el senado fue muy conocida en todas las
audiencias con jueces de la corte con lo
cual me parece que ellos han expuesto
esa habilidad discursiva en el debate de
aliar con mucho conocimiento de política
pública me parece es un debate de mayor
nivel a pesar obviamente los formatos de
los debates televisivos que limitan
bastante la capacidad argumentativa
bien señor berenstein muchas gracias por
sus palabras y esta comunicación él es
un reconocido analista político sergio
berensztein y seguimos hablando de la
cee de la carrera electoral
estadounidense y es que pese a su
contagio por kobe 19 donald trump
regresó a la campaña a un confinado en
la casa blanca esto con una
controversial declaración en un vídeo en
el que dijo que su contagio por
coronavirus era un regalo de dios y
añadió que el uso de un medicamento
experimental le había permitido conocer
directamente su efectividad
en muy poco tiempo me dieron regeneron
es se llama regeneron y otras cosas
también pero creo que este fue la clave
me dieron regeneron y fue increíble me
sentí bien me sentí también hace tres
días como me siento ahora
quiero que todo el mundo reciba el mismo
tratamiento que el presidente porque me
siento genial creo que fue una bendición
de dios que me enfermara fue una
bendición disfrazada que me contagiara
destruya blazing in disguise
acorde a guardia quiero para ustedes lo
que me dieron a mí y haré que sea gratis
ustedes no pagarán por eso no es culpa
de ustedes lo que ocurrió fue culpa de
china y china va a pagar un precio muy
alto por lo que le hizo a este país
antes de skype
finalizamos este bloque en noticias
estadounidenses con la liberación de la
ex policía acusado del asesinato del
afroamericano georg floyd directo bin
salió este miércoles de prisión en
libertad bajo fianza al pagar un millón
de dólares ahora deberá comparecer ante
los tribunales en marzo próximo por la
muerte de floyd a quien mantuvo varios
minutos presionándole el cuello con la
rodilla es el último de los cuatro ex
agentes implicados en la muerte que sale
en libertad condicional a la espera de
juicio la muerte de freud suscitó
manifestaciones contra la violencia
policial en diversas ciudades muchas
derivaron en desórdenes y saqueos
el rebrote de coronavirus sigue
impactando al continente europeo
república checa- ha rebasado este jueves
los cinco mil casos en las últimas 24
horas lo que lo sitúa en el continente
con el mayor número de contagios por
población este país mientras que en
francia el número de nuevos casos
diarios se disparó este miércoles hasta
los 18 mil 746 parís endureció el martes
sus restricciones y hoy jueves se
esperan nuevas y más drásticas medidas y
en españa' aunque los casos siguen en
aumento el tribunal superior de justicia
de madrid rechazó esta mañana las
medidas que restringen desde el viernes
2 de octubre la movilidad en 10
municipios de la región porque alega que
afecta a los derechos y libertades
fundamentales
y como vemos mientras europa está sumida
en una segunda bola el continente
americano registrar récords de casos
brasil superó este miércoles la marca de
los 5 millones de contagios de kobe 19 a
pesar de las cifras el presidente y iron
bolsonaro y algunos gobiernos regionales
siguen con los planes de desescalar
nuestro corresponsable en río de janeiro
valeria saccone nos amplía brasil acaba
de superar los 5 millones de casos de
coronavirus y además está muy cerca de
superar las 150 mil muertes pero los
expertos advierten de que la situación
podría ser mucho peor habría que
multiplicar los casos por 6 eso es cerca
de 30 millones de brasileños podría
haber ya contraído este virus mientras
en las ciudades de brasil vemos una
situación de casi normalidad mucha gente
en las calles el río de janeiro las
playas llenas también los centros
comerciales funcionando como si no
hubiese una pandemia en curso las cero
oficiales muestran desde hace dos
semanas una bajada
los muertos se quedan por debajo de los
700 diarios sin embargo hay que recordar
que brasil es un país enorme de 210
millones de habitantes y los focos se
van moviendo entonces hay mucha
disparidad entre una región y otra por
ejemplo sao paulo la ciudad más afectada
ha tenido una baja pero desde hace unos
días la curva se ha bajada se ha
estabilizado el río de janeiro también
que es la segunda ciudad más afectada
del país ha habido cambio a lo largo de
las últimas semanas hubo una bajada de
los casos luego hubo un repunte de casi
dos semanas
ahora parece que de nuevo los casos
están remitiendo manaos la ciudad cuya
imagen dio la vuelta al mundo porque
hubo que cavar fosas comunes e se está
planteando la posibilidad de imponer un
lock down de unas dos semanas frente a
un nuevo repunte del 30 por ciento de
los casos en general la situación es un
poco caótica y al mismo tiempo analógica
podríamos resumir de esta forma el
brasileño hace su cuarentena como mejor
le parece
y estás cansado de esa situación y
prefiere mirar para otro lado
primera reunión en ginebra de los
mediadores internacionales en el
conflicto entre armenia y azerbaiyán
para intentar mediar un alto el fuego en
la región de nagorno karabaj
mientras el escalamiento continua los
reporteros de france 24 en azerbayán se
encontraron con habitantes en el lado
hacer de la primera línea de combates
ellos muestran orgullo nacional y fervor
por el conflicto lo que ayuda a explicar
el impulso para recuperar lo que ellos
consideran como un territorio ocupado
aunque armenia afirma tener reclamos
históricos y étnicos sobre esta zona
a unos pocos kilómetros de la primera
línea artillería sacude al campo hacer y
cada día estos habitantes se reúnen para
observar la batalla desde la cima de una
colina y creemos en nuestro presidente
estamos junto a él así que tenemos que
pelear allí iremos
es la misma expresión de orgullo
nacional que se escucha en todas partes
en un país que prepara a sus niños para
la guerra uno de los hombres abre las
puertas de su casa en la que construyó
un refugio apresuradamente
este es nuestro refugio nos escondemos
aquí mi familia mis hijos mi esposa mi
madre nos metemos aquí y salimos cuando
el seguro lo usamos todos los días todas
las casas en este pueblo tienen refugios
como éste
esa fuerte detonación indica que las
fuerzas armadas de azerbaiyán están
disparando cerca
pero a pesar del peligro algunos se
rehúsan a escapar incluso esta mujer de
97 años
no nos vamos a ningún lado no hay duda
de eso
en la principal ciudad cercana a la
gente dice que los negocios están mal
muchos clientes se mantienen fuera de
las calles pero en esta panadería los
hornos están llenos y el personal está
trabajando a pleno
atendemos a cualquiera que venga aquí
pero también enviamos pan a la primera
línea a nuestros soldados
escarrer
y horneamos para ellos y los alimentamos
como madres y tías consideramos que es
nuestro deber
en cámara nadie expresa ninguna duda o
temor y mire para finalizar la poetisa
estadounidense louise block gana el
nobel de literatura- 2020 así lo anunció
la academia sueca con sede en estocolmo
en el premio de literatura como el resto
de los galardones nobel se entrega el 10
de diciembre en el aniversario de la
muerte del fundador de estas
distinciones alfred nobel
1993 louis se hizo con el premio
pulitzer por el poemario el iris salvaje
los dejamos con estas imágenes y ya con
france24
[Música]